erst zehn jahre alt und schon jetzt hat
sie ihr geschlecht gewechselt oder soll
man besser er sagen man weiß es nicht
heute früh noel dies als junge geboren
und jetzt auf dem laufsteg als mädchen
das bei der fashion week hier sehen wir
sie eher mit ihren eltern in new york
sie wurde dort auf die weltbühne gezerrt
offenbar schon auch um zu zeigen das ist
heute alles möglich das ist jetzt unsere
gesellschaft auf der anderen seite ist
sie halt gerade mal erst zehn jahre alt
als model auf dem laufsteg er und sie
soll das entschieden haben dass sie ihr
geschlecht wechseln möchte und jetzt
eben dort auf der laufsteg bühne der
welt dort soll sie zum neuen transgender
star werden
ihr name kellermeier ihre besonderheit
die kleine engländerin ist das jüngste
transgender model der welt es ist
einfach unbegreiflich zehn jahre jung
transgender und auf den laufstegen
dieser welt zuhause nur lameck may
geboren als junge und jetzt als neue
binäres model das heißt nicht eindeutig
zu einem geschlecht gehörend erfolgreich
schneller lief auf der new york fashion
week und wird als star gehandelt mutter
die identifiziert sich heute als trans
männlicher mann angeblich habe ihr sohn
schon mit zweieinhalb für sich
festgelegt dass er nun ein mädchen sein
will in puncto geschlechtsidentität kanu
eller vor uns mit dem auto heraus so die
mutter als er sechs jahre alt war wurde
in der geburtsurkunde aus junge mädchen
laut daily mail war nur als leiblicher
vater dagegen konnte sich aber nicht
durchsetzen
die geschichte von mohamed maher erregt
zahlreiche gemüter viele werfen ihren
eltern vor sie in eine bestimmte
richtung zu drängen als model da sind
sich experten sicher kann er bald die
erste laufsteg million verdienen ein
zehnjähriges transgender model völlig
irre oder das neue normal
ein transgender star was geht ihnen
durch den kopf wenn sie dieses mädchen
hier sehen sie mal auf dem laufsteg
sehen ist das eine weg der gut ist der
richtig ist spricht das für eine offene
gesellschaft oder ist es nicht
vielleicht auch ein weg um an sagt lasst
doch die kinder noch ein bisschen kinder
seien nicht nur auf dem laufsteg sondern
vielleicht auch selber sich erst mal
finden bevor man entscheidungen trifft
also ich halte von der vermarktung vor
allen dingen kindern überhaupt nichts
für welches politische anliegen auch
immer das finde ich sollte ich nicht
gemacht wenn ich im nächsten spiel gar
keine ahnung was da geht bei solchen
themen geht es um sehr sehr schwierige
fragen für eltern die uns gar nicht in
die öffentlichkeit gehören die schwierig
genug sind die zu entscheiden aber das
zum gegenstand jetzt von werbekampagnen
zu machen und kinder zu vermerken das
finde ich die vollständig daneben und
können daran exemplarisch das ist ein
aspekt aber das thema dahinter ist ja
schon sparen transgender und die frage
die wenn wir die mädchen oder jungen ins
gesicht gucken nur ladis zehn jahre alt
und die eltern behaupten sie hätte mit
zweieinhalb schon für sich irgendwie
rausgekriegt dass ihr geschlecht das
falsche ist glauben sie so eine
geschichte
also das klingt eigentümlich und es ist
schwer einzelfälle zu bewerten ich kann
nur sagen bin selbst vater dass es gibt
viele viele schwierige fragen gibt in
der erziehung von kindern und so einen
körper ganz gewiss dazu und deswegen
gefällt mir die platte form der
aufarbeitung in keiner weise und nochmal
an sollen eltern helfen die in
schwierigen situationen sind und nicht
dass die noch dazu beitragen ist das was
sich die kinder wieder fährt dass das
noch öffentlich vermag damit das ist der
springende punkt das verbietet sich
glaube ich auch dass solche dinge
öffentlich zu verlieren und werden über
ein kompliziertes thema da bin nicht
gegen platte kampagnen weder in die eine
noch in die andere richtung ralf stegner
vielen herzlichen einkäufe ihre
einschätzungen zu diesem thema
[Musik]